hi I'm Erik Bosse and every holiday
season there's a handful of movies that
I watch friends and family the top of
that list is home alone for a kid
growing up in the early 90s there really
wasn't a better fantasy that a kid who
talked back to his parents and nearly
murders burglars and eats the most
delicious mac and cheese oh wait he
doesn't he just leaves it there on this
channel we typically dive deep into the
analysis and stuff you missed from
superhero movies another nerd stuff but
I figured why not break down something
you might actually be watching right now
so here is a special holiday breakdown
of all the interesting details you might
have missed in home alone so here we go
let's start at the beginning
McAllister's house was shot on location
in Winnetka Illinois a suburb of Chicago
it's actually just down the street from
the church that Kevin goes to in the
movie and we meet the McCallister family
including Kevin McCallister Macaulay
Culkin and his parents Kate and Peter
played by Catherine O'Hara and John Hurt
and his siblings buzz Megan Linney and
Jeff and Jeff I always recognize as a
kid as the elder Pete from Pete and Pete
on Nickelodeon and right away Jeff plays
a little joke on Harry Joe Pesci casing
the house and disguised as a police
officer he nearly hits him and he's kind
of foreshadowing a big moment later
actually that later paint can knocks out
Harry's gold tooth which Kevin spots in
this scene where it sets off a red flag
alerting him that something's fishy
about this guy it's way that he
recognizes him as the same guy later the
little Neuros pizza guy arrives and he
knocks over the McCalister statue sets
off the movie's recurring joke of
drivers running into it constantly
little Mears is obviously a play on
Little Caesars and Kevin pisses off his
whole family in the kitchen where we
meet fuller his cousin who wets the bed
Fuller's actually played by Macaulay's
younger brother kieran culkin who grew
up as an actor in his own right he
appeared in Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
and the show succession this scene
contains my favorite miscible detail in
film see director Chris Columbus was
concerned that home alone central
premise a family leaving a boy home
alone on Christmas Eve would be too
implausible like how could a family do
this so he went to great lengths to
justify all the ways the parents could
overlook missing their son while leaving
the country and here is the best example
of that attention to detail look closely
as kevin pushes buzz and he spills the
milk it spills on the passports in the
plane tickets which Kevin's dad mops up
with napkins and tosses in a big pile in
the trash Columbus includes an insert
close-up of that trash can with Kevin's
ticket visible among the garbage right
before it gets covered up
and before we move on to miss opening
sequence it also introduces us to old
man Marley neighborhood snow shovel er
who kindly salts the sidewalk so people
don't slip on the ice the boys like to
tell urban legends that Marley keeps the
bodies of people he's killed buried in
the salt I actually ran another theory
that the reason he salts the ice is
because his wife slipped on that ice and
died maybe because his son was supposed
to salt the ice as a chore but he forgot
and that's why the partners I don't talk
to each other anymore but yeah I don't
know not everyone whose salt sidewalks
does it for morbid morbid reasons the
next morning the family over sleeps and
rushes to make their flayed and we get
another knocked over statue gag followed
by the family scramble now the music of
this movie was composed by John Williams
and for me he is a big reason this movie
feels so timeless but actually the music
here may sound familiar to you Williams
actually borrowed the whole
orchestration melody from Tchaikovsky
the Russian dance from The Nutcracker
listen closely John Williams is
obviously one of the greatest film
composers ever but he does admit that a
lot of his iconic scores were inspired
directly from classic composers like
Tchaikovsky and vogner outside Kevin's
cousin Heather gets a head count of all
the kids counting the neighbor kid
rooting through the airport shuttle van
which screws up her count which allows
them to overlook Kevin but re watching
closely in addition to this Heather
actually counts herself twice so yeah
they had no chance at recognizing that
their numbers were off now this airplane
is filled with little cameos from the
directors family the woman in the red
sweater is Chris Columbus's
mother-in-law and the baby that she's
holding in lap is Columbus his daughter
meanwhile the first-class flight
attendant is played by Columbus's wife
Monica now back at the house Kevin
realizes he has the place to himself and
he goes through Buzz's stuff now the
picture of Buzz's girlfriend has a whole
story behind it the director didn't want
to ask a young girl to pose for this
photo because he didn't want to
traumatize a girl by calling her ugly so
we got around this by having his son
dress up as the girl although I gotta
say from personal experience it doesn't
exactly feel great to be a boy and be
called an ugly girl wolf now the rubbish
Kevin watches as this old movie called
angels with filthy souls which is not a
real movie they shot it specifically for
home alone but it is based on the James
Cagney movie angels with dirty faces and
Kevin slugs down two stairs out the
front door which you know it doesn't
take a genius to see that it
would not work the stairs would lead
Kevin directly into the wall now by the
way this shot of him launching out the
front door along with all of Kevin's
more dangerous stunts throughout the
movie were played by a 30 year old stunt
actor named Larry Nicholas
he was short enough to fill in for Kevin
from a distance at least next we meet
the Wet Bandits Harry and Marv played by
Joe Pesci and Daniel Stern they roll
into the neighborhood and they're OK
plumbing van what you don't think about
it kind of ties into Marv's dumb calling
card of flooding all the houses that
they hit look maybe Marv is a plumber or
the guy who owns his van is a plumber a
friend of his so by flooding all these
houses it could create more business for
them the phone number on the side of the
van begins with jk5 which if you look at
the letters on an old touch-tone that
would make this five five five which are
the three digits that all phone numbers
and movies and TV begin with McCallister
family arrives in the Paris Airport
closely on the other side of that glass
in the background you could see a family
holding a welcome banner now that was
actually going to be a joke but it was
cut from the film this is going to be
Uncle Bob and his family who were
grieving them McAllister's are just
gonna tear through this banner like
football players as they rushed to the
phones when Kate calls the cops to check
in on the house larry officer Balzac is
played by actor Larry Hanken you might
recognize him as the scrapyard owner and
Breaking Bad I love how a piece of his
donut falls out of his mouth and sticks
to the phone receiver and a patrol
officer who checks in on the house is
played by Columbus his father-in-law
actually if you look closely you can see
that he also ran his police car into the
statue
later after Kevin runs away from old man
Marley at the drugstore steals that
toothbrush he almost gets run over by
Harry and Marv in their van with the
dodge head ornament telling Kevin to
dodge it the shot was actually filmed in
Reverse when Harry and Marv check in on
Kevin's house later Kevin rigs it up to
look like there's rowdy party going on
now originally Kevin was going to be
playing piano in the scene which would
pay off all the piano lessons he had to
take but the filmmakers thought to be
funnier to see him all strung up and
dancing like this you can see Kevin uses
that cardboard cutout of Michael Jordan
can actually see that Michael Jordan
earlier in the movie on the door to
buzzed his room now as Kate tries to
make her way back to Chicago you can see
at the Scranton airport desk there's
this guy in the background now some
conspiracy theorists believe that this
was Elvis Presley saying that this was
proof that he was actually still alive
eventually some people dug into this and
realize that this guy was of course not
Elvis is an actor named Gary grot this
is where Kate needs Gus Polinski John
Candy's character polka king of the
Midwest
kicker's apparently candy shot all of
his scenes in one day back at the house
we get the creepiest shot of movie
Kevin C and Harry behind him in the
window in the reflection of the tree
ornament you look closely at his
reflection you can see this bark circle
over Kevin's shoulder that's actually
the hidden camera lens and as Kevin
waters a neighborhood emotionally
preparing for burglars to murder him he
stops by the church in makes peace with
old man Marley now notice the band-aid
on Marley's hand here this is a call
back to his injured hand that scared
Kevin earlier at the drugstore the
band-aid shows that it's healing and
it's listened Timah dating to a kid it
reflects Kevin softening attitude to the
old man who still probably murdered
people speaking of bizarre fan theories
as we see Kevin booby-trap his home into
a murder house there were some theories
that Kevin could have grown up into a
psychopathic murderer like another
famous Chicagoan HH Holmes who lured
people into a hotel custom designed to
murder them others said that Kevin could
have grown up to be jigsaw from the Saw
movies now obviously none of this is
canon but a few years ago Macaulay
Culkin did poke fun at this stuff as
mentally disturbed adult Kevin and a web
series episode as an uber driver I
defend off my house from two Psychopaths
home invaders a few fun details about
Kevin's showdown with Marv and Harry the
BB that Kevin fires at Marv's face was
actually hand-painted into each frame by
a low-budget local artists in Chicago
who worked out of his home movie didn't
really have a huge budget for visual
effects Harry burns his hand on the
superheated doorknob and cools it off in
the snow this was actually a nod to
Raiders of the Lost Ark when Thoth burns
his hand on ravenwood's medallion and it
Sears an engraving on his palm Daniel
Stern didn't actually step his bare feet
on the nail god it was made of rubber
and Stern wore fake rubber feet as he
trudged through the snow that would be
really hard to do with bare feet but the
close-up of his feet cracking on the
ornaments was actually his real feet
it's just the ornaments were made out of
candy glass now when Harry and Marv
nearly grabbed Kevin upstairs Kevin puts
Buzz's tarantula on Marv's face Daniel
Stern didn't actually scream out loud
here he just made this face silently
pretending to scream so that he wouldn't
spook the tarantula and he added his
amazing scream by dubbing it over in
post-production Harry and Marv catch up
to Kevin in the house next door where
Harry threatens to bite off his fingers
apparently in one of these takes Joe
Pesci actually bit Macaulay Culkin's
finger leaving a permanent scar there
and
all the details I spot it in home alone
my movie I'm gonna go rewatch right now
because it just gets better and better
with every rewatch comment down below
with your favorite movie to rewatch this
time of year and follow me on twitter
and instagram at a vas and subscribe to
me rockstars for more deep dives into
the movies and the TV you love Marvel's
Star Wars Pixar Harry Potter we kind of
do it all happy holidays and kids stop
telling scary stories about creepy old
neighbors who Isis sidewalks they're
doing you a favor and you know it
they've only killed like two kids on
average tops
[Music]